[Music]
today we're doing a tier list for every
dragon ball arc yes every arc including
super but not gt
[Music]
don't you tell me that it wasn't meant
to be
[Music]
call liquids call it destiny
okay fine i'll do gt let's start from
where it all began search for the dragon
balls otherwise known as the emperor
peel off arc this is a weird one to
start this video off with it is the
starting point of the franchise and it
does feel like dragon ball but this is
clearly a growing period for the
franchise episodic in nature with a much
stronger focus on adventure over combat
despite combat being present the comedic
nature of this short adventure feels
distinctly different to everything that
will come afterwards with that said it
plays host to some of the most oft
flashback 2 moments in the series like
roshi and bulma's introductions goku vs
yancha and of course goku's very first
kamehameha there's humor some weird
creative choices that are extra spiky
looking back at them today but overall
it still retains a lot of the charm that
made it famous it's not my favorite arc
by any means but it does deliver some
nice twists the end with the discovery
of goku's great eight power connecting
it back to his grandpa gohan's death
alluded to at the very beginning all in
all a decent start to the series i'll
give this one a b
next up the 21st tenkaichi budokai now
we're talking this is unironically one
of my favorite arcs of all time and i
cannot believe more people don't talk
about it a while back i decided to
review the original series and even then
i was blown away by how powerful the
messaging and execution of what was at
the time a big change in tone and
direction for the series into the realms
of battle manga looking back now from
the present day with the likes of gods
and intergalactic brawls that can
destroy galaxies being the order of the
day this feels much more quaint and
measured in comparison and to be honest
i love that about this while it's much
more modest and simple these aspects of
the story are absolutely strengths
focusing on and effectively delivering
upon the themes and fostering of the
next generation and pushing your limits
perhaps more effectively than any other
arc that would come later the battle
between roshi and goku is phenomenal and
to this day it's one of the arcs i turn
to revisit whenever i'm hankering for
some good paneling classic dragon ball
action and some good old-fashioned
storytelling this is an easy s-tier
and next up is the red ribbon army
[Music]
here's where we start running into our
first problem in this video what some
people consider an arc others don't and
with regards to the red ribbon army arc
you can further subdivide it into pieces
or look at it as a whole i'm doing the
latter because screw doing it the other
way mr fusion brought up a great point
in the emotional through line of this
arc being that of goku using the dragon
balls to bring back oppa's dad so
naturally the end point of this act for
me is with the uranaibaba tournament
where both of these through lines get
satisfied which honestly raises this arc
in my estimation i personally loved that
tournament particularly through its
ending with goku getting to reunite with
his grandpa gohan for the first and last
time in the series it's touching and
it's still to this day one of the only
two moments in this entire series that's
made me tear up slightly i know this arc
might feel boring to summon on the flip
side might be some others favorites but
for me it lands somewhere in eightier
there's a lot of adventure and fun in
this arc with some crazy characters like
mercenary tao pai pai he has some real
psycho energy in this story and the way
he travels around is so toriyama it
hurts next up the 22nd tenkaichi budokai
the 22nd tenkaichi budokai while it
might be the weakest of the three
tournaments in early dragon ball it's
still an early dragon ball tournament
arc and thus is an easy a-tier contender
the fundamentals are all there for a
great story concerning manipulation
staying true to yourself and of course
my soft spot fostering the next
generation the three main tournament
arcs in early dragon ball when viewed
through the lens of master roshi tell
the story of a grizzled vet looking on
hoping praying and doing everything in
his power to ensure that long after he's
gone there will exist someone better
than he to look after the earth and it's
in this tournament we really get to
experience that as for the very first
time for us roshi loses opting to leap
out of bounds in his match against tin
shinhan for his own good proving ten
shinhan in that moment that winning
isn't what's important to roshi but
everything else that comes afterwards
furthermore the matchups in this
tournament are awesome too with the
likes of roshi versus attention on of
course goku vs krillin and naturally the
final match up goku vs 10 shinhan with
tenshinhan's very soul on the line and
with there existing the possibility that
this could be the very first time goku
could win a tournament it's an edge of
your seat affair and i just loved it i'm
sort of on the fence with this one
should i put it in s tier or should i
leave it with a the first tournament i
still feel is a little better i think
but only by a fraction still it's enough
to push this to a tier i think king
piccolo arc the king piccolo arc on the
other hand is an arc that i don't think
i share a lot in common with the rest of
the dragon ball fanbase given i found it
difficult to get past a few hiccups i
saw the story to have but let's talk
about some of the good points first
because in reality there's a lot to like
here and i do want to give this arc its
fair due it's ending ushers in of course
an iconic battle between goku and king
piccolo himself with a level of
seriousness to it the likes of which we
had never seen before from goku which is
appropriate as this is goku in his
teenage years and the last time we'll
see him as a child before becoming a
fully-fledged adult and not to mention
both one of the coolest defeat moments
for a main villain furthermore i love
the connection at the end goku receives
to the heavens with god and on top of
that yet again upon rereading i was
blown away by how great goku's first
interaction with yajirobe actually was
and i love how filled with anger goku
became when krillin dies in the story's
opening moments it's tragic and horrific
to see particularly off the back of what
was a great and respectful contest
between goku and tin shin on in the
finish during the last arc but i do have
some gripes with this arc as i mentioned
so let's explore those while it has
elements that are great to me it felt as
though they were cobbled together by
tenuous plot beats that existed solely
to move the story along despite them not
actually making all that much narrative
sense in the first place the first
defeat goku receives soundly at the
hands of king piccolo is great but king
piccolo only leaves the scene when he
recognizes that goku's heart has stopped
and once he leaves
goku's heart coincidentally just turns
back on we'll call that contrivance
number one okay that's contrivance
number one contrivance number two comes
by way of goku being in the company of
the only person who could carry him to
safety and not just that
manage also to climb corinth tower goku
was the first to climb the tower and god
knows how long i mean that's what made
that specific achievement so special but
now because the plot demands it yajirobe
can do it too that's convenience or
contrivance number two okay that's
controversial contrivance number three
once up there the lesson goku received
from corn in that keep away game now is
flipped on its head with no real message
apart from i guess he took a big risk by
drinking the special water to make him
stronger
cool and now gets a free power boost to
allow him to defeat king piccolo there's
no lesson there's no story arc really to
speak of that's meaningful outside of
roshi coming to realize that his time as
the earth's defender has come to an end
and he doesn't even really play a large
enough role to carry the story this time
around it's a real shame this arc has a
lot to offer and while i still think it
leaves a lot to be desired it's still
the blueprint for villain-centered arcs
that would be later perfected as the
series soldiered on into dragon ball z
with that said i just can't put it
anywhere higher than a b-tier personally
but that's okay because the next arc
marks what i believe to be the beginning
of the single best run in all of dragon
ball and that run begins at the 23rd
tenkaichi budokai i think at this point
it should go without saying that i am
something of a super fan for these early
dragon ball tournament arcs with the
first acting as one of my favorites in
the series this the 23rd tenkaichi
budokai might actually be my favorite
arc of all time alongside two others i'm
sure many of you could guess to me this
arc marks the beginning of my favorite
stretch in dragon ball's long and
winding story and i think for this arc
we gotta dust off that god tier once
again because man this is a god tier
level entrant if ever i did see one
almost every single fight in this
tournament is an absolute banger and i'm
serious like all of them ten shinhan
versus his former mentor tao the
adorable chichi vs goku fight krillin vs
piccolo and yamcha versus shen offering
yamcha perhaps his best moment in the
original run despite him still losing
and those are just the quarter-final
match-ups it's got a rematch between
tienen goku and of course we have goku
vs piccolo in the finals the likes of
which i cannot believe there are still
folks out there that have watched and
loved dragon ball z and still haven't
seen this one because this is the part
of early dragon ball that really started
to feel like z for me and this final
fight specifically is better than so
many of those great fights we get in z
to boot it's incredible offers so much
in the way of choreography so much so
that later fights borrow from this very
fight itself i could talk about this arc
honestly for the next half an hour and i
have done on my channel so if you want
to know my thoughts on every aspect of
this arc in detail you can go there but
for the sake of brevity i will be
placing this in a new category called
god tier
now it's time to march onward to dragon
ball z starting things off with the very
first arc of z entitled the saiyan arc
now oddly enough given that i'm a
reviewer and love dragon ball it might
surprise many of you to know that i've
reviewed every single part of dragon
ball including gt
except for the series's most popular
section dragon ball z and since i have
every intention to one day review these
arcs in detail i'll be sharing with you
all my ratings for these arcs now
however i will try to keep them brief
this is a tier list after all and we
have a lot more to get through after z
concludes alright so the saiyan arc this
was the arc that literally started it
all for me way back when i was a little
kid i got to see goku vs vegeta and to
this day it is still my favorite fight
in all of the series and maybe even all
of anime it's an arc that kicks off with
a change that takes a story from the
limitations of earth to the broad
expanse of the greater universe it kills
goku in its opening chapters i mean that
never happened before and the journey to
and training with king kai remains to
this day one of my most treasured
moments in the series this arc is top to
bottom brilliant and i can't wait to one
day explain in greater detail why this
is my opinion but for now
we're putting this in god tier
the frieza arc the freezer arc is
another incredible contender for this
tier list and one that's catapulted my
imagination into the stratosphere i will
say right now that i am including the
dynamic portion of this tale in this arc
too meaning the captain mouse games that
made our first trip outside the confines
of earth all the more thrilling and
enjoyable are also included in this arc
it also has a moment that legitimately
scared me to my very core as a kid when
brian drummond's vegeta screamed in
anger after he discovered gohan stole
his dragon ball i'll get you for this he
won't escape
hearing that voice that anger my soul
would leave my body and furthermore it
elevated the intimidation that vegeta
represented in the story which again was
leveraged brilliantly from that point on
through encounters with the ginyu forest
that served to elevate goku far beyond
what we ever expected from him and then
there's the frieza fight which offered
gohan a number of occasions to be badass
and of course vegeta's death and goku's
ultimate fight with frieza which also
provided for me my favorite goku moment
in the series and it's not the super
saiyan transformation it's the kaioken
times 20. acting as one last hopeless
struggle to maybe touch the untouchable
god frieza had built himself up to be
the ending to this struggle is perfect
and i totally 100 plan on going and
diving into this in greater detail
another day but for now again
this is another god tier entry
next up the garlic junior r okay look i
know this arc is in canon but i included
it for funsies okay
sue me whenever the series would pop on
my tv screen and the freezer arc would
end i'd eagerly await the return of goku
in his little space pod only two time
and again get faked out by this weird
zombie vampire mini arc featuring gohan
krillin and piccolo truth be told the
concept behind this little story isn't
all that bad and actually has a few
scenes that i remember vividly like the
gang turning into weird vampire zombies
by the black water mistant and of course
kami and popo running in the depths of
the lookout it adds a bit of color and
fun to the world of the lookout too but
to be honest that's where my compliments
end it's at the end of the day a
needless detour with no consequence for
the main plot and adds nothing of
serious value the action is lacking
toriyama's touch and overall was never a
story i wanted to revisit in this series
this is our first c tier entry totally
met in hindsight and now we're on to
what everyone's been waiting for the
cell arc now we're back to cooking with
gas with the cell arc comprising
everything concerning frieza's surprise
return with trunks's reveal the
android's material and of course the big
green handsome men of the hour so this
arc is pretty nuts and not always in the
best of ways but boy does it introduce
some imagination capturing mechanics and
sticker landing so incredible we are
still talking about it all these years
later for me i look at this more like an
epilogue to what was in my opinion the
greatest stretch in the original run
from the 23rd tenkaichi budokai all the
way to cell you have for yourself this
brilliant story of how goku assumed
responsibility for earth all the while
learning that not everyone can be
reasoned with furthermore goku's son
gets introduced during the saiyan arc
and within that epic conclusion to this
arc against cell we get a thrilling and
immensely satisfying conclusion to that
story also it does have some really
obvious issues that i have to draw
attention to for the sake of honesty
though the fact toriyama had editors in
his ear telling him that the main arc
villains weren't good enough is clear
for all to see as we shift focus from
jerome 19 to 17 and 18 and eventually to
cell who cycles through a bunch of
different forms before landing on one
they all light it can be a little
distracting but getting to see the
unveiling of trunks the return of goku
and vegeta and as i mentioned that
awesome conclusion during the cell games
it more than makes up for those
shortcomings narratively it's not god
tier for me but it's definitely the top
of s-tier it's a terrific arc
and now we're moving on to the final arc
of z the boo arc what now i bet everyone
is waiting for me to tear this arc a new
one but to be honest i don't hate this
arc i just think it's the weakest of z's
run i made a video discussing this arc
shortcomings before so if you want to
take a look at that video you can but
truth be told despite the arc having a
lot of weird padding for lack of a
better term it's filled with so many
iconic mechanics and stuff from the
series that have lasted the test of time
it's difficult to hate it too much super
saiyan 3 is awesome and who wouldn't get
that satisfying feeling watching vegito
do what no one else could do
effortlessly it's an empowerment fantasy
in the best of ways also when i was a
kid i will admit i totally tried to do
that thing gohan told videl to do with
her chi so that she could fly yeah okay
i was that kid that believed he could
fly and you know what else i also try to
do the kamehameha my childhood was
awesome jokes aside though when i was
playing sports growing up and i needed a
small boost kaio ken really did do the
trick and i even tried revisiting that
little mental trick a few months ago
when i ran my very first marathon in
june and it did give me a boost at mile
20 though i did pay for it later totally
true to the kaioken mechanic what can i
say while the boo arc itself does suffer
from a major course correction and a
lack of direction during many instances
it boasts some of the most emotional and
epic clashes in the series too i don't
think it's as good as all the other ones
but it's definitely not the worst from
the original series i'll give this one
an a and that brings us to the end of
the original series and to the end of me
being upbeat and happy it's time to dive
into the misery as we enter the post og
series material with 1996
dragon ball gt
the gt stands for good television just
kidding just kidding it doesn't it
stands for garbage tv i lied
the black star dragon ball arc
please refer to my review i made a few
years ago my opinion hasn't really
changed only sadness and hatred remains
and look i think or at least i hope that
a lot of you out there at this point can
appreciate that on some level perhaps
differently from you i adore this story
i love dragon ball i love how it's made
me feel throughout my life and heck a
minute ago i even admitted to channeling
the power of the kaioken in the middle
of a distance race when i was 30 years
old but i think it's because this story
means so much to me that when i see it
go so far away from what i loved about
it i can't help but react in a
let's say a displeased manner concerning
what i've just seen enter the black star
dragon ball arc many of you if you're
from america might not have even seen
this arc because it was cut and all of
you guys basically got the start from
the baby ark instead a much much better
arc than this i wrote a comprehensive
review of my first time watching this
series in completion and this arc in
particular was worse than i remembered
instead of building off of the material
dragon ball had left us with in the
original series it violently changed the
tone of the narrative without any
transitional period creating scenarios
with no through line anyone over the age
of four could get behind and more often
than not left me wanting and yearning
for a story i'd ultimately never receive
keeping also in mind that much like the
original series i too grew up with this
show so this isn't the case of me being
cynical in my older age either overall
this arc is just a mess aimless in its
direction and offered absolutely nothing
i could latch onto and enjoy personally
by far the worst arc on this list it
does have a great theme song though but
that alone cannot save it from my wrath
here time to dust off f-tier truly awful
the baby arc okay this arc wasn't awful
not even close to being awful really and
honestly was the arc goku and the gang
should have opened with in this new
series i'm definitely not the first
person to mention this but there are
some truly interesting and exciting
ideas and concepts at play here and i'm
not talking about super saiyan 4. the
idea of creating a physical
manifestation of the saiyan's hatred and
chaos in the likes of the parasitic
life-form known as baby offers not just
interesting visual possibilities and
hijinks with tension built in but it has
something the arc prior didn't a through
line that connects it to the earlier
material thematically i love the idea of
baby being created to get revenge for
what the saiyans did only to become what
it was designed to destroy a monster
attacking a new world it's a simple idea
but a powerful one and it's easy the
arc's strongest aspect i think
furthermore i love what this arc did for
goten when i first saw this i
legitimately laughed out loud it's such
a fun idea for the character to give him
this lady killer persona however i do
have issues with this arc too the first
half of the story is interesting
watching as baby infiltrates the gang's
group however once that point passes and
the main set pieces fall into place the
narrative doesn't feel like it has much
else to offer and sort of meanders a bit
until the fight at the end the
interesting fights that interval of
narrative tension are replaced by just
plain old fighting that honestly feels
more like an obligation than a tangible
part of the narrative and has an ending
with a giant golden monkey fight that i
genuinely did not enjoy even in the
slightest baby has its problems for me
but i will say that it has more good
than bad and is comfortably the best arc
in dragon ball gt for me overall i think
i'll give this one a b for baby
[Music]
super android 17 arc one step forward
with baby and now 20 steps back with
super android 17. god i did not like
this arc when i watched it last and i
still don't this has one of the loosest
excuses for a story i've ever seen the
plot is cobbled together by tenuous at
best plot elements and at worst totally
nonsensical choices the fighting is
immeasurably boring and i couldn't care
less about the main villain either if i
tried it's cool that piccolo is in this
but even with that this still manages to
suck beyond belief it's only saving
grace is that it's short so it's biggest
upside for me at least is that it ends
faster than the other acts brilliant i'm
not spending more time on this than i
need to f tier moving on the shadow
dragon's arc ah the final arc of dragon
ball gt's one year run capping things
off in 1997 with its shadow dragons arc
an arc that again everyone might say has
an interesting plot concept and it does
however the execution manages to turn
that into something much more boring
than it otherwise has any right to be i
will however say that while it is boring
in many aspects it does have some
upsides the spirit bomb goku charges at
the end is awesome and up there with the
best spirit bombs in the series it
offers some of the most memorable dragon
ball gt action despite that not meaning
much in hindsight and it has by far its
greatest achievement and ending
deserving of dragon ball that will
always bring a tear to my eye but
and this is a massive
donkey dog the ending to dragon ball gt
doesn't really have much to do with the
arc itself in theory the gang have
overrelied on the dragon balls all
throughout the series and so if you tack
this ending onto the end of any of the
other arcs from the past it works just
as well as it does at the end of this
one it for that reason feels
disconnected in many ways and it also
feels strange to consider it part of the
shadow dragon's act for me good as it is
it feels like an ending that was
conceived of independent of the ark
itself and to be honest given it has
little connective tissue to the main
story i think that very well could be
the case as an arc as a story the shadow
dragon's arc is interesting and far less
bad than the likes of the black star
dragon balls and super android 17 but
it's still nowhere near good in terms of
storytelling for me personally with that
said i'm going to slot this shadow
dragon's arc into d tier and with that
it's time for a time skip not in the
narrative of the story though but uh in
in real life remember that remember real
life me neither time for dragon ball
super dragon ball super kicking off
right after the release of the
impressively mediocre resurrection f
film the powers that be behind dragon
ball super's creation saw fit to recap
not one but two films in significantly
lower quality with little to no extra
content worth exploring let's see how i
thought that went the battle of god's
arc i don't think a single show has
given me more whiplash than this right
here when i heard that dragon ball was
returning for the very first time since
i was a little kid i legit got chills
i'm sure like many of you and readied my
body for the awesomeness i was
anticipating to commence when i found
out that they were recapping a film that
came out two years prior i was
disappointed and then i saw this face
yeah
that became the face of dragon ball
super for me i was destroyed and look
it's not like there's anything
necessarily wrong with this story but
there's nothing really in this arc
that's done better than the film itself
i suppose i liked in theory the notion
of extending the fights to match the run
times of the z fights but there was
nothing of substance really added
there's an entire episode where goku and
beerus literally threatened to punch the
universe in half and it's by far one of
the dumbest things i think i've ever
seen in this show and i've seen some
dumb things in this show overall i'm
flirting with the idea of putting this
in c tier but the animation is just so
bad i have to put it into detail
the resurrection f arc resurrection f on
the other hand was a film i thought left
a lot to be desired however what they
did add to this while it's better than
what battle of gods offered nothing new
outside of goku and vegeta's training
episode which i still like this is still
a massive step backwards in every
conceivable way managing to make a film
i already didn't like even worse by
tanking the animation more than i had
ever seen in the prior arc while also
being in and of itself a pointless
retread it's worse than battle of gods
but it's still deteri the universe 6
tournament arc i was hyped to see this
arc i was hyped to finally see some new
stuff from dragon ball that wasn't a
retread of the older films the ending
itself is flashy and fun but i'm going
to call a spade a spade here and this
this might be controversial but i
thought this arc was boring with that
said however it is still nowhere near as
bad as the prior 2 arcs and offered up
something new at the very least for us
to enjoy i like some of the fights or
well i should say i enjoyed part of some
of the fights i like the theme behind
vegeta versus kaaba although the action
felt a bit limited i liked the super
saiyan transformation part of goku vs
frost and i liked goku vs hit i think my
favorite part of this was funnily enough
not the kaioken though i did like that a
lot but i found myself having more fun
with goku finding his footing against
hit himself in the early stages of the
contest there's a lot of fights in this
but overall i think it's the weakest
tournament arc in all of dragon ball
it's not bad but it's not great either
it's a really middle of the pack type
arc so i think i'm going to put it in
seat here
the jelly vegeta arc
you've got me kidding me wait i forgot
the uh the the other world tournament i
forgot to include that in this video um
okay i if you're counting that as a
tournament arc that's worse than this
one uh so if i'm putting this in seat
here i'll put the other world tournament
in d tier
yeah i didn't like that tournament
speaking of not great let's talk about
the disaster that was jelly vegeta truth
be told i know that's not the name of
this arc but it's the one that literally
everyone online uses and so for the
purposes of this video and [ __ ] it
henceforward that's the official name i
hear by decree the ark itself is super
short feels totally pointless and feels
like it incorporates the likes of goaten
and trunks more out of pity than any
other reason they're just not using the
story much the same way i included
garlic junior for the lulls i'm throwing
this one down in f chair because i found
it so annoying to endure i will say
though that brian drummond coming back
as the voice of jalita was a really nice
touch in the english dub so there's
and i'm black that
and i'm blacker than black and i'm black
y'all and i'm blingy black blacker than
black black i'm blacking it black yo
because i'm black
you know what's funny about dragon ball
super it started off in the worst of
ways but managed to crawl back from the
abyss and deliver a better arc each and
every time it released one think about
it the first two arcs were aids the
universe 6 arc was ok if not boring and
now we have goku black otherwise known
as the future trunks arc not bad a train
wreck of an ending but otherwise not bad
well that's perhaps being a little too
generous i've gone on the record and
stated numerous times that this arc
feels like there's a lot of padding and
that more importantly the logic of the
mechanics in this story don't actually
makes any sense when you sit down and
think about it and the writers knew that
i think
aside from having the worst ending in
the series i think there's a lot to like
about this arc and it managed to deliver
one of the most iconic characters to
stem from super's three year run goku
black himself furthermore there are
interesting conversations on topics that
are being contended with here between
right and wrong moral superiority and
different ethical dilemmas many of which
are glossed over and not dealt with but
while we're flirting with answering
these questions in the middle of the
story it's interesting at the very least
the action in this is easily the best in
the series thus far and even managed to
bring some fans back that otherwise gave
up on the show after animation gate in
2015. choosing where to place this is
difficult but at the end of the day i
think it's better than universe 6 by a
wide margin but nowhere near as good as
the 22nd tenkaichi budokai so
i guess plopping it in b tier is
acceptable for me
the universe survival arc for those
curious by the way of my comprehensive
thoughts concerning this arc as well as
all the other super arcs i made a series
a couple of years ago where i go through
everything and my feelings are pretty
much the same now as they were back then
so check it out if you're curious with
that said i probably will sound a lot
more positive in those reviews than i do
here where i'm comparing everything from
super to the very best from the original
run and with that out of the way let's
talk about the anime's conclusion with
universe survival arc and the tournament
of power itself some people love this
some people hate this arc with a burning
hot passion personally i find myself
landing close to the middle maybe
leaning a bit more to the side of
enjoying it all things being equal
though i think this arc is much better
than goku black however i think goku
black is a much better antagonist when
compared to the likes of jiren and
before i hear in the comments oh jared
wasn't an antagonist yes he was an
antagonist is someone that serves to
stand in the way obstruct or otherwise
antagonize our point of view characters
he isn't a villain that is true but that
is also fundamentally different to an
antagonist an antagonist which jiren is
supposed to be in this aside from that
this arc suffers from a lot of issues
not the least of which being it's a
length with so many fights involved this
is a slog to get through i mean i don't
think anyone thought tien was going to
win this tournament and waiting for him
to get eliminated was a slog if ever i
did see one not to mention a terrible
episode and elimination that he
ultimately received in the end with that
said however when an episode hits it
absolutely annihilated i think if i made
a list of my top 20 favorite dragon ball
super episodes 18 or 19 of them would
come straight from this very long arc
with my number one favorite episode
being episode 131 handled by the now
household name of magubi ishitani who
would later go on to do amazing things
with one piece episode 131 of super is
breathtaking in all of the best ways
both narratively and visually thanks to
the likes of yuya takahashi contributing
one of the coolest moments in the series
through frieza and goku's team up
despite frieza's recruitment early on
being amazing and major story beats in
the plot being solid the arc itself has
a lot of padding moves at glacial pace
and jiren sucks beyond belief vegeta
repeats character moments he had in z
time and again and overall there are
great moments but equally disappointing
ones and flaccid moments to boot i think
due to that i'll give this one a b tier
2. but top of b tier better than goku
black in my opinion and to be honest i
think if we cut this act down by maybe
35
this act would get a much better ranking
in this list
the morrow arc if i'm being perfectly
honest i wasn't sure if i should even
include the morrow arc from the manga as
the manga itself feels like an entirely
different story for a multitude of
reasons i mean the universe survival arc
is so different from the anime in the
manga that i put the manga version of
the events into detail if i could so
that will tell you just how different
these two versions of the story really
are with that said however i do want to
include this as it is part of the
ongoing dragon ball story and it is an
arc i felt weird about the moral arc
however while i was reading it month to
month because of the way the manga is
laid out and the way the action doesn't
really do anything when you're caught
waiting for a particular fight to end
for three months at a time you tend to
lose interest really fast and almost
forget certain plot beats however for a
binging experience with this act being
completely done and being able to read
it from start to finish in one go this
arc was a lot of fun offered vegeta a
nice piece of character development
which is more than i can say for pretty
much all of dragon ball super and we got
to go back to namic for a bit which is
always good again like the other parts
of this video i wrote a full review of
this arc a couple of years back when it
concluded and to be honest it holds up
really well it's not as good as the 22nd
tenkaichi budokai but it is worthy of
being an a tier entry i think at least
for now maybe below or around the boo
arc and that should do it i'm not going
to cover the granola arc seeing as it
hasn't finished yet and i'm not caught
up on it either i do plan on reviewing
it someday soon though it's just got to
end first but yeah that's my tier list
let me know how stupid or wrong you
think i am in the comments down below
and don't forget to scream at me on
twitter if i don't get at least 50
people screaming at me in my mentions i
sometimes worry that twitter has gone
down or broke or something i love you
all one piece review next week and then
the world i've been toying that mark
thank you all so much for watching and
i'll see you all next week
uh
[Music]